mark vanilla this vide made me laugh and
was fun but it was hard for me to watch
because I'm not gay what and five people
agree how is there are those first
mighty face and why had the only one who
kind of wanted to eat his hair six
thumbs up I think my hair would taste
quite salty because I use a sea salt
spray to get it to like stay up so I
don't think my hair it tastes very good
ELISA Ali your head looks fake and weird
law
it's that insult
yes in cocea did she [ __ ] no will be
the arts I don't fight on camera I just
hold that right in and wait till the end
Billy Jo Saxton how do you grow your
hair how do I grow my hair by a natural
process I'm sorry Marcus I hate to say
this but every single time I watch your
videos I for some odd reason think of
the octopus from the Wiggles
not gonna lie I have no idea what the
Wiggles is nor what the octopus from The
Wiggles is I like calamari squid same
family frost the Hedgehog them are
bizarre that's lucky cuz I'm wearing a
vest today so there you go that's PA mr.
frost Salma Ibrahim says you don't like
my old teacher when your hair is wet and
no makeup mm-hmm thank you good good
Nico Kuroda your smile is so
persuasive spaces like you look like
Aaron pool two thumbs up now that's
amazing because I kind of love Aaron
Paul hey y'all
[ __ ] kilee Potter I saw you have a nice
lamp and I have it to others excellent
we're lamp twins
good good lamp with light inch pip Hyde
says Althea's bigger legs old better fit
Boyd says Alfie has better legs than me
my legs are not better than a girl's
legs although her pictures of Zayn so it
could secretly muse Ain my legs are not
better they're like so hairy trust me
you don't want legs like this I'm like a
werewolf